c'était il ya 4 1 4 1 an et demi lors
des dernières élections québécoises
c'est pas moi qui a gagné dans
taschereau c'est nous autres c'est tout
le monde
c'est tout le monde qui arrive à gagner
dans taschereau c'est pas moi catherine
dorion qui a gagné donc pour québec
solidaire était une des dix députés élus
lors de la dernière soirée électorale
elle est avec nous catherine dorion
bonsoir bonsoir la passion et votre
moteur on l'a vu dès les premiers
instants de votre élection est-ce que la
passion déjà quitté pour la politique
non pas du tout et d'ailleurs je vois
beaucoup sur les antilles catherine
dorion quitte la politique je vois pas
les choses comme ça moi je vais je suis
une militante depuis 10 15 ans je fais
de l'art engagé j'arrive en politique
j'amène dollars de la passion politique
et le je veux continuer sur ce chemin là
en étant plus présente sur le terrain
mais pour des luttes comme la nécessité
d'un tramway à québec pour des luttes de
ce genre là moi je vais être là encore
après puis je suis devenu en quelques
jours une sorte d' influence euse dans
la région de québec que je vais
continuer à faire ça mais je veux avoir
le temps de me consacrer à des projets
artistiques qui vont être des projets
engagés qui vont toujours être
socialement et politiquement engagé mais
est-ce que vous n'étiez pas devant un
débat qui se présentent à plusieurs
personnes c'est à dire est ce que je
dois rester à l'intérieur pour changer
les choses poussées faire avancer les
choses être dans des commissions
parlementaires poser des questions ou je
sors et je peux encore avoir une
influence mais ça sera autrement quand
même exactement mais beaucoup de gens
vont dire ah ben là c'est quoi qui est
mieux puis l'on peut même s'estimer sur
un an fois les à l'intérieur pour
changer la machine à l'intérieur ou faut
faire pression de l'extérieur en fait
pour que notre projet de société
réussissent le type de 2 pour
l'environnement pour la justice sociale
toutes ces choses là pour que ça
réussisse on n'a pas le choix d'être
partout puis c'est ce que je pense en ce
moment je pense qu'il ya dans le monde
artistique une forme de réveil en ce
moment politique qui va être très fécond
et auquel j'ai envie de participer mais
en politique aussi il ya un retour vers
la mobilisation vers le lien avec le
terrain puis ce sage y croit beaucoup
mais est-ce que c'est utile une députée
catherine dorion c'est utile mais ça
dépend ce qu'on en fait le rôle de
député c'est vraiment un job que ça
dépend ce qu'on en fait j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu être très peur puis allez
dans un juste dans les soupers spaghetti
peseiro jambes et j'ai pas de pouvoir le
ministre a dit non puis m'arrêter
l'autre mais moi j'ai décidé de faire
sept jeux blancs avec tout ce que
j'étais avec tous les leviers que je
pouvais imaginer fait qu i will bien sûr
allait être au parlement et l'assemblée
nationale faire pression en poussant les
ministres mais il ya aussi
organisé des mobilisations comme celle
qu'on va faire de même pour le tramway y
auprès de 1000 personnes intéressées le
déjà une grosse mobilisation pour le
tramway demain soir à 19h ce on a même
des représentants de la société civile
des élus de toutes sortes et trans
partisan c'est fort faire ça mais ça un
député peut prendre d'initiatives comme
aux fesses zanetti d'invités de faire
c'est très beau mais justement j'en
reviens avec l'exemple du tramway
catherine dorion mais si vous étiez
resté député
si vous aviez continuer à poser des
questions dans des commissions faire des
et des dés regroupent avec les
journalistes d scram et c est ce que
vous n'auriez pas eu si vous aviez été
réélu bien sûr plus de pouvoir que vous
nous lui l'aurait comme militant dans
des groupes c'est sûr que la question de
ou 20 g avoir le plus de pouvoir
beaucoup de monde en politique qui cela
pose moi je suis une artiste et je suis
allé en politique pas pour avoir du
poids mais pour inspirer pour créer un
peu de ce que je considère pour pour
amener de l'intelligence émotionnelle
collective dans le peuple je veux
participer à ce je pense qu'on a besoin
je pense qu'il ya des changements
sociaux importants qui doivent arriver
qui arriveront pas si on développe pas
ça fait que moi je suis dans cette
recherche le sait sa maquette c'est ce
qui me porte c'est ce qui donne du sens
ce qui me fait vivre bon en fait je
cherche ce avoir le plus de pouvoir moi
ce poste que je cherche comme personne
moi je cherche à ce que les gens qui
n'en ont pas en est plus je trouve sa
bonne société où le pouvoir est pas
concentrés en eau comme il l'est
actuellement
c'est une durée c'est sûr mais en fait
c'est la même version gpo d les gens qui
vous ont élu des gens qui ne se sentent
pas assez représentées à l'assemblée
nationale il ya quand même un - au bout
de l'opération de vous quitter et vous
allez me dire à quelqu'un d'autre sera
là mais ce que vous représentiez avec
les choses qui pouvaient choquer les
gens voient tenue vestimentaire plains
pas c'est pas important que ça reste à
l'intérieur que ça sorte pas je pense
qu'il va y en avoir d'autres c'est si
vous dites oui vous avez dit n'avoir
d'autre mais moi je fais ce pari là
parce que si je mets ça sur mes épaules
en disant je dois rester jusqu'à
l'infini parce que sinon ça ne sera plus
là c'est fini c'est moi je faisais pour
qu'un mouvement c'est un mouvement faut
que d'autres personnes s'engagent c'est
un peu le message que j'ai fait quand
j'ai sorti ma vidéo pour faire cette
annonce là aux citoyens de taschereau
faites le si vous trouvez que c'est trop
contraignant que ce cadre là n'est pas
pour vous c'est parce qu'on a besoin de
voix politiques faut qu'il y ait des
gens qui ont du bagout une grande gueule
puis envie de péter les cadres qui
rentre dans cette institution le c'est
essentiel je les fait pendant quatre ans
je suis fier de ses quatre années le
puits le message que je fais tous les
québécois en fait c'est goa les hits et
plus vous êtes différent plus vous est
important pour aller dans cette
institution lopy
sinon on si on laisse les gens qui
aiment cette institution laïque qui
veulent s'est conformé y aller on est
foutu parce que si on réussira jamais à
faire les grands changements importants
qu'on a besoin de faire mais partir vous
dit ce n'est pas être un peu foutu je
n'ai pas renoncé non pas du tout parce
que comme je dis un peu partout depuis
ce matin il ya plein de milieux qui ont
besoin d'applications je me j'ai lu
récemment que rené lévesque avec la
discussion avec ferment du monde devient
épique toi applique toi que fernand
dumont lui avait dit il faut qu'il y ait
des militants dans le monde intellectuel
dans le monde artistique dans le milieu
du militantisme à l'assemblée nationale
etc c'est cette conjonction là qu'il va
faire qu'à un moment donné un mouvement
social sera possible
catherine dorion je dois vous laisser
aller merci beaucoup nous avoir parlé à
la prochaine merci beaucoup au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit